Es gibt immer etwas zu tun. 15 Jahre führen
Manja und ihr Mann Duncan
jetzt schon das Glenfinnan
House Hotel.
Sie kümmert sich um die Gäste,
er um die Küche.
Und sie haben das Haus
wieder hochgebracht.
Mittlerweile können sie auf eine ganze
Reihe von Auszeichnungen stolz sein.
Das Hotel liegt malerisch am Loch Shiel:
ein altes Herrenhaus aus dem
18. Jahrhundert.
Tourismus ist hier in den westlichen
Highlands ein Saisongeschäft,
aber die Sommermonate sind gut gebucht.
Zum Fleiß gesellte sich das Glück.
Durch die vielen Harry-Potter-Filme,
die sie hier gedreht haben,
läuft es bei uns in der Loch-Harbour-Gegend
einfach phänomenal!
Die Filmcrews haben oft hier
im Hotel übernachtet.
Denn nur einen Steinwurf vom Hotel
entfernt fährt er jeden Tag
über das weltberühmte Glenfinnan-Viadukt:
Harry Potters Zug.
Vor Harry Potter war Glenfinnan
und seine Umgebung
nur eine abgelegene Gegend an
der Westküste Schottlands.
Jetzt ist die Region ein
Touristenmagnet.
Doch all das ist plötzlich bedroht –
durch den Brexit.
Denn nach dem Willen der britischen
Regierung sind EU-Ausländer
als Arbeiter bald nicht mehr willkommen.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist,
dass wir einfach nicht genügend
Arbeitskräfte hier in der Region haben,
um die Sommermonate zu überstehen.
Das ist ein echter Kampf.
Wir haben es über die lokalen
Jobcenter versucht,
aber die haben nicht genügend Leute.
Es ist einfach unmöglich.
Und macht die britische Regierung
ihre Drohung wahr,
wäre Manja auch persönlich betroffen.
Denn auch wenn sie schon fast 20 Jahre
in Großbritannien lebt – sie ist Deutsche.
Die Kinder waren schon schockiert,
als sie vom Brexit gehört haben.
Vor allem die Kleine!
Und sie haben gesagt:
„Oh nein, Mami! Jetzt musst du weg!“
Und ich habe ihr gesagt:
„Na, das wird schon nicht passieren.“
Aber es ist ein Riesenthema in der
Familie und in der Schule.
Jetzt im Frühling ist die schottische
Westküste ein farbenprächtiges Bilderbuch:
felsige Hügel, blühende Ginster
und stille Buchten.
Zweimal pro Tag dampft der Zug in
der Hochsaison an Glenfinnan vorbei.
Er schlängelt sich durch die Highlands
und schließlich am Meer entlang.
Das kleine Fischerörtchen Mallaig
ist Endstation.
Rund fünfzehntausend Touristen
besuchen es jeden Monat.
Und der Zug ist für die Bewohner
der abgelegenen Region
so etwas wie ihr persönliches
Harry-Potter-Wunder, sagt sein Besitzer.
Der Zug ist wirklich wichtig,
wenn man sich anschaut,
wie viele Leute wir hier
nach Mallaig bringen.
Sonst gibt es ja nur die eine Straße.
Ohne uns würden die Geschäfte leiden.
Denn Fischerei gibt es in Mallaig kaum noch,
stattdessen Hotels, Restaurants, Cafés.
Ohne den Tourismus wäre
die Region am Ende.
Über 200.000 Jobs hängen von ihm ab.
Duncan wirbelt schon in der Küche
für das Abendessen.
Er kultiviert die feine schottische Küche.
Das Glenfinnan hat sich auch gastronomisch
einen Namen gemacht.
Das Restaurant ist gut besucht.
Um den Service aber kümmern
sich ausschließlich
Ausländer aus Bulgarien,
Ungarn, Litauen.
Monika arbeitet die erste Saison hier,
aber sie war schon öfter in Großbritannien.
Als ich dieses Mal hierhergekommen bin,
war es schon anders am Flughafen.
Sie haben mich gefragt, warum
ich hierherkomme.
Auch Konstantin ist einer von zehn
EU-Ausländern,
die im Glenfinnan House arbeiten.
Letztes Jahr war er noch Barmann,
aber dieses Jahr ist er schon
stellvertretender Hotelmanager.
Er kann nur hoffen, dass es für ihn
gut weiter geht.
Wenn das mit allen EU-Arbeitern
hier zur gleichen Zeit passiert,
dann gibt es wohl einen Aufstand.
Denn ich glaube nicht, dass die britische
Wirtschaft ohne EU-Arbeiter überleben kann.
Sie haben einfach nicht genug Leute.
Manja sagt, ohne Ausländer könnten
sie zumachen.
Immerhin hat sie für sich noch einen Plan B.
Ich könnte mich auch um die
britische Staatsbürgerschaft bemühen,
aber ich hoffe, dass ich das
nicht machen muss.
Ich wünsche mir immer noch, dass alles
in Ordnung kommt
und vernünftige Regelungen für
EU-Bürger gemacht werden,
die hier schon so lange leben und
auch bleiben wollen.
Draußen wird es Abend und das Glennfinnan
bekommt noch unerwarteten Besuch.
Noch sind sie zuversichtlich hier,
dass es am Ende doch nicht so
schlimm kommen wird.
Aber seit dem Brexit-Referendum
leben sie mit einer bösen Ahnung.